is there a relationship between changing
your evidence versus changing your model
and the psychoanalytic repression so
repression would be saying you know what
that data doesn't exist let me ignore it
versus the
perhaps a cognitive behavioral therapy
technique would be to say no go out and
perhaps update your model of it view it
differently view the maybe it's our
arachnophobia for example i think it's a
beautiful analogy and you know not
probably beyond an analogy
there are people in computational
psychiatry who think exactly like that
um and you know
you can find articles trends in
cognitive science reviews of the car you
know certainly deal with you know how do
you how do you resolve cognitive
dissonance how do you understand wishful
thinking um so examples
i think that's a perfect example of
this way
of maximizing the evidence for your
models of the world in that case it
sounds like at least the colloquial
understanding maybe in the west or maybe
throughout the world i'm unsure is that
you should update your model you
shouldn't try to change the evidence to
match your model you should update your
model and in fact there are some
political implications i'm sure people
shout that on the streets across various
political divides so is this an argument
to say that updating the model is
actually the one that should be primary
because the way that i understand from
how you've explained it is that both are
equally valid however when i look across
the world and look at how we think just
in terms of common sense psychological
advice at least to us in the 21st
century it sounds like you should update
your model um well but i think you're
right to say that you know it would be
um
disingenuous from a mathematical point
of view to privilege the model versus
the data and
um
so how does one choose between those
mathematically how does one i don't i i
i don't think you can in the sense you
know you you can't you can't spit a coin
a coin has two two sides to it i mean
um the whole point of this inactivist um
uh take on sense making
um is the it you know you you have to
optimally go and listen to the right
kind of news talk to the right kind of
people um in order to solicit the right
kind of data that's going to maximize
the evidence for your model whilst at
the same time you are updating your
model um sometimes known as basically
palpitating um
or certain basic model selection for
example so the two things go hand in
hand i think one way of resolving or
answering your question is just to
say in a political um
or um
perhaps even sort of um
communication science uh sense or
at least
the social aspects of it um what you're
what you're saying is that um
there is now
once you acknowledge that you also are
in charge of getting the data
um
then then you also have to contend with
the problems of how much weight you
afford to that data versus that data and
where you get your data from which news
channels do you uh do
forage
who do you listen to who do you trust
who do you ignore
um
and we do this all the time we do this
in a very skillful way so personally um
in terms of deploying
our attention
so if you're an engineer
and you are thinking about
assimilating visual information using a
kalman filter for example
then one of the most artful challenges
or art for resolutions that the cameron
filter brings to the table is to get the
kalman gain right how much weight do you
afford
the prediction errors that supply the
update term of
filter
and we we do that on the fly all the
time right down to the level of
turning on and off
the attention or the precision or the
gain
afforded
visual information